so the number 197 and what i'm going to
do is i'm going to add the three digits
so 1
plus 9 plus 7 is 17. now what i'm going
to do is i'm going to form a number out
of the last two digits of the original
number and the the new number nine
plus seven
plus seventeen and that is thirty-three
and now i'm going to do the same again
so it's seven
plus seventeen plus 33 and that gives me
57. you're beginning to get the idea 17
plus 33
plus 57
and that gives me 107. and now brady
you've been very patient
the keith number is about to emerge 33
plus 57 plus 107
and look what i get when i do that
i get
197.
that's quite interesting like i can't
decide if these would be really really
rare or really really common i
intuitively it strikes me this would be
rare they're very rare this is a number
with three digits there are only 80 of
order 80 numbers 80 keith numbers
with less than of or 80 hang on i don't
like this of order
there are in fact 84
keith numbers
with
um less than
uh 26
digits
once you get a digit once you get more
than three digits how do you start this
process say you talk with two seven
eight five for example
then you would begin
your process with two plus seven plus
eight
plus five which is equal to 10 17 22
and the next stage along the line is you
take the the preceding three digits and
add the fourth from the new number so
it'd be seven
plus eight
plus 5
plus 22. there are for example two digit
numbers okay so if i take d equals 2
then 14
is a keith number you go 1 plus 4
is 5. 4 plus 5
is nine five plus nine
is fourteen
mike keith
who's a mathematician
uh and discovered them in 1987. for me
this is recreational mathematics it's
it's how i got into mathematics uh my
hero wasn't a
physicist early on it was actually a guy
called martin gardner i'd never heard of
euler sadly
earlier on
when i was at school and gauss but
martin gardner was this guy brilliant
mathematician that worked i knew him as
a as the
guy working for scientific american and
i subscribed to scientific american and
i never understood a single
article i read
i kept trying to understand i'd re-read
it and i'd just be it'd be a blur but
the mathematics he had this mathematics
puzzles at the back
and then i i generally couldn't do them
either but i was fascinated by them
there were little numerology things
and
then i went and bought some of his books
and just got into it just playing around
with numbers and you just get to love
them
so the people who watch number file and
get a bit sniffy about our recreational
maths videos what do you say to them oh
you shouldn't you should just enjoy it
embrace it and just have fun just have
fun playing around with them there's
plenty of occasions when
you're
doodling thinking what shall i do and
just play around with numbers and you'll
be amazed some of the coincidences that
can come up and uh
and and out of some of these things come
major breakthroughs we're not quite
finished there's just a couple more
things which uh um are around there
there's one called the the reverse keith
and this is where so again it's best
just to show you an example of a reverse
keith number it's where the reverse
number appears in the sequence so if i
begin say with 12 okay
so we just follow the prescription that
we've had so we go one plus two two plus
three
three plus five
five plus eight
eight plus thirteen
and that's equal to twenty one
and that's your reverse keith number
you've reversed the order of the uh
the integers in in in the original
there's even fewer of what you could
call keith clusters keith has got a
conjecture about these keith numbers his
numbers he's allowed to have a
conjecture about his own numbers of
course
and they're to do with the clustering of
these numbers
and what he's done is he's said
how many ways can you cluster the keith
numbers such that in any cluster
which could have
of course the cluster has to have more
than one number so it could have two
numbers three numbers four numbers each
number in that cluster is an integer
multiple of the lowest number this
conjecture is the following here there
are three
that are known just three and he says
that's he believes that's all there are
so i think it's quite an interesting
challenge for some of the number four
people to go and maybe find some more
so um
so here's here's an example of a keith
cluster so the number 14
and 28
are both keith numbers
and of course 28 is twice 14.
and another keith cluster is the number
well one thousand one hundred and four
and then if i double that
two thousand two hundred and eight we've
also got to have the same number of
digits in the sequence there is
remarkably one cluster of three
keith numbers
which which is
three
one
three three one
of course six two six six two
nine three
nine nine three i think that's amazing
each of those are keith numbers they all
satisfy the properties that we've been
describing and they form this cluster so
the conjecture is that's it
i used to i used to do these puzzles on
the bus going to school i had to get two
buses
and uh i'd just try and do well whatever
i could quite usually i got stuck
especially with the geometrical ones he
has geometrical puzzles as well as sort
of basic algebraic ones and then he has
all puzzles on paradoxes
you know the
how can you get uh
infinite number of people in a hotel
with an infinite number of rooms and
then
double the number of people and things
it was great